oh he's weirded out by you excited yeah
that means so much sense morning
everyone as I'm like just trying to
spend more time in create context I I've
been running in parallel one-on-ones and
these smaller groups and this is the
biggest group I've done this with mainly
I just want to kind of take more
opportunities in 2018 to like
download you guys on on things on my
mind things that I'm seeing and create
opportunities for you guys to just ask
me questions and things of that nature
so that's the the spirit of this morning
I just walked through the the
renovations so I'm so crazy I'm so
excited it's gonna look so amazing so
obviously a couple weeks from now
I'm sure the vibes are gonna be pretty
extraordinary it's a 2018 so off to a
really interesting and exciting start
for me my dream when I started this
company was create the greatest
communications machine hence why we have
every capability media buying creative
studio publishing and be very
comfortable in doing for good or profit
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right like it we haven't
even started with how intense this is
all going to be we're gonna be at the
forefront of it as a communications
machine we started as a community
management shop the excited
[Music]
that means so much sense this company
did one thing eight years ago you paid
us and we replied to people on Twitter
so there's a lot of things that I want
to be better at this company I could
probably spend the rest of my day
putting them on a list but at a macro
we're so right and so to offset it I
want to be able to be your muse on your
micro right I want to fix your micro
because on a macro we're gonna win and
you and I'm so thankful because so many
of you have been here for a while I just
want you to win in that environment my
success is that I prefer change I'm
comfortable and change and I realize
change is the only thing that allows you
to win in the long term the 98% of the
human race and maybe hired doesn't like
it we are having a macro change we're
having a societal change you know like
I'll be honest with you I'm like
ambitious and realistic one of the
biggest reasons I kind of went even
harder core at my personal brand like 15
months ago like back to what's worked
for us which is like hey here's my
example at least it's something to hold
I was like [ __ ] it I'm gonna make myself
the most famous person in America on
this theory and then they'll be
undeniable and by the way it's working
I'm really good at underpriced attention
and culture I really am
you know what's so funny you start
realizing your life so I was good at
baseball cards I decided Frank Thomas
and Kenny loften we're gonna be better
than most people thought so I just
bought a lot of rookie cards for
underpriced costs and I was right but
what I'm really great at is I understand
consumer behavior and attention just
fast enough and earlier than most people
and I've got an uncanny ability of that
let me build a machine around that and
so the last nine years I've built a
company called Manor media we're 200
million-dollar company in revenue with
no funding that does agency
and we own a female publishing company
like a refinery29 and my ambition is to
build out the communication Deathstar to
deploy it against my personal brand the
nonprofit's I care about but ultimately
my goal is to buy the New York Jets and
the way I think I'm gonna do that is I'm
gonna buy iconic brands and things that
mattered in the world that are gonna get
[ __ ] over the next decade and then I'm
going to rebrand them and run them
through my machine and so I'm you know
I'm building this huge agency media
company that is really just a front and
a proxy for my long-term ambitions
it just it pleads underpriced attention
and culture more efficiently than I
think any other machine out there right
now and that's why cool things are
happening for me you please brother I've
been a long-suffering fan since 82 and
somewhere along the line I realized the
only way I'm gonna get [ __ ] Superbowl
is if I do it myself
[Music]
[Music]